imagine Alice traveled back over 50,000
years to find her distant ancestor Bob
now up until this time human culture was
relatively unsophisticated utilizing the
same primitive stone tools which went
unchanged for thousands of years but
somewhere around fifty thousand years
ago something interesting happened and
nobody knows for sure why there was a
sudden explosion of diverse cultural
artifacts including instruments for
making music new tools and other forms
of creative expression humans develop
the ability to externalize their inner
thoughts they began to communicate using
language so Alice begins her search by
looking for water
she knows that human and animal
populations tend to migrate towards and
along rivers which are the lifeblood of
ecosystems eventually she comes across
an interesting marking Bob's handprint
this marking contains very little
information simply that he was here and
could possibly return Alice knows bob is
equally intelligent he can communicate
orally although his culture has not yet
developed the ability to read or write
in their native language at the time the
universal written language was art so
she finds natural materials around her
to paint him a picture in case he
returns she renders an animal she is
tracking hoping this will offer a clue
about the direction she is traveling in
the future our ancestors use natural
materials to create pictorial
representations of their reality here is
an actual cave painting from around
30,000 years ago found preserved deep
inside Chauvet Cave in France similar
renderings are found in the caves of
Spain as well
a common theme among these ancient
paintings are animal forms as well as
the human hand perhaps a signature a
story or a ritual calling
when Bob returns to the waterfall he
finds her painting and proceeds towards
the river where he thinks she might be
when he arrives he does not find her
though he finds a sign that she was here
before he decides to paint her a picture
explaining where he is going next which
is halfway up the river towards the
Setting Sun he has little time to paint
a picture as night as approaching
therefore he needs a fast way to
visualize this message he thinks about
it for a moment and realizes his message
only contains three distinct mental
objects middle River West so he decides
to use simplified pictures to represent
them per River he draws a symbol which
resembles its natural form known as a
pictogram which is a drawing that
resembles the physical object it
represents pictograms are an important
step in the evolution of writing here is
a ceremonial slate palette found in
Egypt dated before 3000 BC the
surrounding scene shows the struggle
between civilized humans in the wild and
ferocious animals
[Music]
however it's difficult to draw pictures
of abstract concepts such as calm old
dangerous or in Bob's case middle for
this he draws a line with a box over the
middle it represents halfway this is
known as an idea gram for a conceptual
picture of an abstract idea here is an
example of the same symbol on an ancient
Chinese bronze inscription for the idea
of West he decides on a picture of the
Setting Sun now he does something
interesting he combines these individual
symbols in terms of their meaning to
create a message meaning + meaning
equals new meaning he leaves this in
help of Alice finding in some of the
earliest artifacts of this symbolic
merging are found in ancient Mesopotamia
now modern Iraq home of the Sumerians
this is the birthplace of many of the
world's earliest civilizations
here we find clay accounting tablets
which are some of the oldest written
documents ever found some dating before
3,000 BC the rectangular tablets record
the payments and cattle shipments of
cattle to Shepherds for fattening and
gifts of cattle as an offering notice
that instead of drawing a picture of ten
sheep they draw a symbol representing
ten using small notches and another
symbol representing sheep or donkey
meaning simply ten sheep we call this
proto-writing finally Alice returns to
the base of the river and finds Bob's
message she interprets a meaning
correctly halfway west down the river so
she marches downriver towards the
Setting Sun and eventually they finally
meet over time Bob learns to speak
Alice's language allowing them to use
the same oral language to communicate
shared concepts and ideas
this gives them an idea the root of a
more powerful written language it starts
with something very simple writing her
name she disassociates the sound from
the picture for her name Alice Alice
this
she combines the mathematical symbol for
all in the picture of ice all ice olice
notice her name has nothing to do with
the individual symbols sound plus sound
equals new meaning this is known as the
rebus principle a great example of this
was found in Egypt along the Nile River
dated to around 3100 BC it contained
some of the earliest hieroglyphic
inscriptions ever found the Narmer
palette depicts the Egyptian pharaoh
Narmer on the back we see him to the
left of a kneeling prisoner who is about
to be struck down by Narmer who we see
standing tall wearing a crown what we
are looking for is on the other side
between the two bovine heads at the top
we see an inscription of his name it's
written as a fish and a chisel which
translates to NARR mer Narmer two sounds
separated from the pictures together
giving new meaning a key development in
the history of written language but
before they could advance towards what
we know of as an alphabet something had
to happen they needed to save time
[Music]